and now I'd like to say - the most
beautiful words in the motion picture
industry Deborah Carr
that's the sweetest compliment ever paid
me hmm you hope your wife will
understand oh it's worth it it takes
weeks to explain it to her I am
delighted to be able to present the
Writing Awards the nominations for Best
Motion Picture Story are Robert rich for
the brave one
leo catcher for the Eddy Duchin story
jean-paul sartre for the proud and the
beautiful and Cesare Sabatini for
Umberto D the envelope please the brave
one Robert wish
mr. Jesse Lasky jr. as vice president of
the screenwriters branch of the Writers
Guild will accept the award for mr.
Richie on behalf of Robert rich and his
beautiful story thank you very much the
nominations for Best Screenplay adapted
our James Poe John Farrow and SJ
Pearlman for around the world in 80 days
Tennessee Williams for baby doll fred
gill and ivan moffat for giant and
Norman Corwin for lust for life the
envelope please in Hollywood the winner
is around the world in 80 days
for John Farrell and myself thank you
and in New York and himani bingo will
accept the award for mr. Perriman
this film would never be sure II hope he
will be able to live up to it or live it
up and he said
the nominations for Best Screenplay
original are Robert Lewin for the bold
and brave and Wellstone for Julie
William rose for the lady killers
Federico Fellini and Tulio Pinelli for
La Strada and Albert Lee movies for the
red balloon the envelope thief in New
York the red balloon out the glamorous